bienvenue à auvers sur oise nous allons
découvrir durant cette promenade à vélo
ses paysages du val d'oise qui ont
inspiré les peintres impressionnistes à
la fin du 19e siècle
pizarro cézanne bobigny et bien sûr
vincent van gogh ont arpenté à vélo la
campagne et traquer la transformation
des paysages par l'oeuvre de la lumière
c'est à vous maintenant d'imaginer ce
que vous voyez avant d'enfourcher votre
vélo vous pouvez rendre une petite
visite à ces lieux aujourd'hui symbole
du mouvement impressionniste
le musée daubigny la maison du docteur
gachet ou encore le musée d'absinthe
mais maintenant en route il est temps de
rentrer dans le tableau
mémorisez bien les photos suivantes car
la signalisation routière est quasiment
absente sur la première partie de the
bar au centre ville d'eau vers
engagez-vous dans la roue des ponceaux
plus adroite au de léry
à gauche ensuite aux aubigny où vous
rencontrerez l'atelier dobbin ou devrait
sans doute mettre pied à terre pour
franchir ce petit chemin
tourner à gauche au prochain carrefour
une formidable sensation d'espacé de
liberté commence à naître dans ces
paysages au sol très riche
prenez à droite sur cette départementale
puis tout droit sur valmondois à
valmondois prenez à gauche sur la
départementale 151 en direction de
nesles la vallée
nous arrivons dans la vallée du
sausseron une petite rivière que nous
longeons quelques kilomètres
sur la départementale 64 nous rejoignons
la belle ville et vallons bouchard les
premières maisons typiques du vécu soit
faite de pierres calcaires de tuiles
apparaissent ainsi que de nombreux rue
vers josip ans
traverser ensuite valant bougeard et
suivre la direction et pirus par la d64
route que vous quitterez rapidement pour
prendre la direction de mai nous ville
sur votre droite vous allez adorer ce
petit détour devant nous la ferme manoir
du petit-château vestiges d'un haut lieu
d'exploitation agricole au deuxième
siècle le pigeonnier octogonale composé
d'une tour massive faite de pierres et
de briques est l'une des parties les
plus spectaculaires de cette ferme
château
notre route se poursuit en direction de
theuville mais quelques centaines de
mètres avant ce village vous prendrez la
route des pierres russe sur la gauche
repérée bien ce carrefour où vous
prendrez à droite pour rejoindre le
centre-ville des pieds continuer cette
route par lee villiers puis en direction
de nri vous traverserez la
départementale des 27
après une seconde route traversée vous
prendrez à gauche dans cette zone
résidentielle
vous retrouverez une direction
auvers-sur-oise par la d27 via le rond
point de la des 927 vous regagnerez
auvers-sur-oise par le château d'auvers
qui vous propose un voyage au temps des
impressionnistes
une visite qui clôturera agréablement
votre balade
et si vous prenez un peu d'altitude
revenez au menu principal et
sélectionnez le parcours de la route des
crêtes une vue unique sur la scène à
plus de 115 mètres de hauteur
tout
il
troisième
le
kuhn
ce parcours débute au parc de la
villette en bordure du canal de l'ourcq
symbole de l'oeuvre urbaine le parc est
aussi devenu grâce à l'aménagement des
quais de l'ourcq la grande porte
parisienne vers la campagne
ce trajet exceptionnel vous passerez du
coeur de la ville au coeur de la
campagne grâce à une piste cyclable que
nous suivons 30 km le dépaysement est
assuré et l' aventure accessible à tous
types de vélos
l'itinéraire est très simple puisque
vous n'emprunterait qu'une seule piste
cyclable iriez-vous d'abord vers le pont
du périphérique ou travers serait
ensuite une petite zone industrielle la
première ville de saintes zanni que vous
traverserez les pantins nous avons serez
en toute tranquillité et sécurité sur un
revêtement alternant bitume de bonne
qualité avait été stabilisé à partir des
pavillons-sous-bois le canal se resserre
et perd son caractère industriel pour
faire place à la navigation de plaisance
peu à peu la verdure se fait plus
présente et plus sauvage
après livry gargan prenez garde aux
piétons car la piste cyclable est aussi
empruntée par les riverains des villes
qu'elle traverse
à partir de sevran nous sommes en pleine
campagne
mais la piste cyclable n'en demeure pas
moins de bois de qualité
notre parcours s'arrête à claye souilly
le canal de l'ourcq eux se poursuit et
traversent encore trois départements
jusqu'à la ville de port aux perches en
picardie pour venir à paris les plus
sportifs referont le parcours en sens
inversé les autres prendront le rer b à
sewen
revenez au menu principal et découvrez
la balade en vallée de seine un parcours
d'un niveau de difficulté équivalente
le
une
nous sommes dans la ville de la roche
guyon dans le parc naturel du vexin à
moins de 70 km de paris une ville connue
surtout pour son château et sa
forteresse médiévale qui domine la
vallée de la sée mais l'intérêt de ce
parcours le plus sportif et notre
sélection réside dans la surprenante
roues des graines à une centaine de
mètres d'altitude
elle offre une vue spectaculaire sur la
scène alors suivez le guide
étonnant château de la roche guyon
composé d'un donjon qu'on sera à
l'époque médiévale ou 12e siècle et des
pavillons monumentaux et terrasses bâti
six siècles plus tard notre route débute
donc au pied de cet imposant monument
nous allons d'abord longer la scène par
là des 913 en direction de veto soyez
attentifs au fléchage suivant arrêté y
sus de l'indication au décrète pas la
décence nous allons prolonger notre
parcours et quitter cette route en
prenant un direction de la goulée
villers en arthies
vous arpenterez une route magnifique
très paisible et ponctuée de quelques
montées
à villers en arctique prenez en
direction de villarceaux par la petite
route de haute sourire au golf de
villarceaux vous aurez parcourir 15 km
depuis la roche guyon
mais la route des crêtes nous attend
alors cap sur chossy pucher ans par là
des 171 une route qui commencent par une
plaine puis monte graduellement à
charance vous suivrez la route des
craintes quand tout à coup un paysage
extraordinaire va se révéler sur votre
côté gauche
nous sommes à 115 mètres d'altitude un
point de vue unique et vertigineux sur
la scène
par temps clair on peut voir le fleuve
serpenter d'est en ouest sur plus de 10
km
notre parcours s'achève par une superbe
descente sur la roche guyon et la scène
en suivant la départementale 100
pour continuer votre parcours dans la
vallée de la seine revenez au menu
principal et sélectionnez la balade en
vallée de seine
was you
que
nous sommes dans le village de freneuse
département des yvelines en bordure du
parc naturel du vexin à 70 km de paris
ce parcours longe la seine qui à cet
endroit décrit une boucle d'une
vingtaine de kilomètres la forêt lots
seront un décor principaux de cette
balade qui ne présente pas de
difficultés particulières dans le
centre-ville de freneuse suivait la
pancarte indiquant tennis ski nautique
quelques mètres plus loin vous arriverez
sur les rives de la seine nous sommes
bien dans une vallée au pied de falaises
calcaires la balade commence sur ce
petit chemin de halage praticable par
tous types de v
le suivre et soit quelques centaines de
mètres pour rejoindre la d 37 1
direction de la commune de la vacherie
en bordure de cette route de petits
chemins permettent de s'approcher au
plus près de la scène et d'admirer
l'autre rive la forêt de moisson sur
votre côté droit est parcourue par de
nombreux sentiers que vous pourrez
explorer en vélo tout terrain à la
vacherie roulait en direction de moisson
par là des 124 qui dispose d'une piste
cyclable
puis suivent et lava cours par là des
on
peu après la vague cours vous
traverserez la base de loisirs de
moisson mousseau pêche baignade golfe
d'avril à septembre vous pourrez
profiter des nombreuses activités de la
base suivez-la des 125 direction de
mousseaux sur scène vous retrouverez
alors des bords de seine plus aménagé en
passant à la hauteur du barrage de
méricourt
retour à freneuse notre boucle est
terminée il reste à la seine près de 150
kilomètres à parcourir avant de se jeter
dans la manche pour l'accompagner
quelques kilomètres encore plus au nord
revenez au menu principal et
sélectionnez le parcours de la route des
crêtes
cette balade est la plus courte de notre
sélection est certainement la plus
dépaysante aussi comment croire qu'à
moins de 45 km de paris par l'autoroute
a4 se trouve cette petite poche de
nature intacte est désormais protégé
c'est la volée du grand moulin du nom de
ce petit fleuve 220km affluent de la
marne
n'attendez plus attrapez votre vélo et
français prendre un immense bain
d'oxygène le temps d'un après midi la
partie la plus intéressante de ce
parcours se situe entre tigeot notre
village de départ et la vie ne soit une
dizaine de kilomètres sur lesquels nous
nous concentrerons
ati jours vous pourrez déjà faire
connaissance avec le coran morin votre
côté gauche inquiets d'un très grand
charme a été aménagé en bordure de la
rivière a le très calme idéal pour se
décontracter y observer la nature
nous poursuivons notre parcours en
rejoignant dammartin sur tige ou par là
désinv
environ 200 m après l'entrée dans un
martin prenez bien garde à prendre à
gauche à cet endroit précis des
pancartes indiquent la direction de la
mairie et d'une école contourner
l'église sur la droite puis toujours
tout droit
nous arrivons dans les hauteurs de la
vallée
le paysage se déroule devant nous dans
une légère ondulation et dans un calme
complet
cette petite route nous mène jusqu'au
village de guerra vous prendrez à droite
au début du village
plus un peu plus loin sur la gauche
joindre celle en bas
respirer
cette route qui plonge dans la vallée
est tout simplement sublime
elle nous transporte à des centaines de
kilomètres de paris
au coeur des cévennes dans les
contreforts du massif central
la végétation est varié et fourni ils
ont apprécié ses parfums humides et
boisées
à la salle en bas prenez la route du
grand morin sur la gauche nous croisons
la rivière à ce moment le plus bas
jusqu'à la ville
pour retourner sur tige ou vous pouvez
revenir en arrière ou prolonger votre
balade en remontant la vallée par
l'autre versant dans ce cas emprunter la
d 25 au carrefour de villeneuve jusqu'à
cette petite route à prendre sur la
gauche en direction de rouilly le bas
prenez ensuite la première à droite
c'est un virage en épingle qui vous
amènera à willow
on
haro issue fait la route pour le char
noir
il
puis toujours tout droit pour
redescendre son petit jo par la route du
grand lieu de montherlant
envie d'une balade à vélo plus culturel
revenait au menu principal et
sélectionnez le chemin des
impressionnistes
was you